etwa als erste mal in kunst und humor
technik macht mit acht stationen und
jeweils drei durchgänge hoffe dass die
die arme heben drucken bilden und ihn
darum
da waren wir unseren laden also die
rhythmus kann natürlich über weltkrieg
die handflächen blick nach vorn
sie hat vor und streckte darum immer
wenn die anstrengung ist das ausatmen
roben mit rucksack habe gewicht
erstkontakt mit ellenbogen und knie um
das richtig die 19 range of motion aus
nutzer erstellten verspüren abgelegte
fuß gehen dann wären damit so laut ich
zu jeder station
[Musik]
und noch einmal aufs spiel
damals vor üben für scharfschützen
nächste woche kommt und dieser hat
gleich mit der sicherheits belehrung und
wo man gelernt haben wie man sich zu
verhalten haben und wer für was zum
beispiel zuständige ist das geld zum
beispiel der leitende ist und so zum
beispiel für für sicherheitsoffizier
gestellt ganz wichtig die waffe ist die
mir gesagt haben das ist kein volles
magazin madeira fällt dann geht es jetzt
um ihr zum ende und der krieg selbst
einmal zum üben jeder 2k patrone habt
ihr schon mal patronen gehabt oder wenn
man den hauptplatz das nächste
wochenende beim festplatz mit die kab
tonnen genau gibt
[Musik]